what is going on everybody welcome back
to the channel I'm your host Warren and
we have some announcements today about
the Channel slash just the cosmic Wonder
in general one you might already know
about you might have stumbled upon this
just by happenstance actually two you
might have actually just kind of
stumbled upon before but one is brand
new and I know most people if if not
nobody has stumbled upon by themselves
because it's brand new and that is a
patreon account the cosmic Wonder team
now has a patreon account and yes we are
going to be hosting exclusive content on
the patreon including some leaks that
you know that some sources tell me some
links that are also posted online
everywhere that we can't really talk
about on YouTube sometimes
hope Marvel and DC aren't watching this
right now
but we're going to be posting a lot of
things on there there's going to be a
few different tiers that's already up
right now you can just type in the
cosmic Wonder on patreon or I'll put the
link down below you can click on that if
you want to donate anything to the
channel super appreciate it all the
money that is going to come from patreon
is going to go right back into the
channel it's going to go right back into
creating not only better content but
more content we already post once a day
here but we wish we could do more but we
need more help essentially so anything
that goes from anything that y'all put
to the patreon is going to go right back
into the channel so appreciate any love
and even if you just watch our YouTube
videos to support we super appreciate
that as well and we love you all three
thousand now the second one is
we have a website yes we have a website
where we're going to post a lot more
than we post on YouTube like I said we
only post once a day on YouTube Just
because of everything that it takes to
post once a day on YouTube sometimes
twice and that takes a lot as well but
on the website we're gonna post a lot
we're gonna post as much as we can if
anything really big happens we'll talk
about it of course we'll talk about it
on the YouTube channel as well but
there's a lot of other kind of medium
little stuff that happens every day too
that we don't talk about on the channel
That We're going to be posting to the
website that and we're going to talk
about more than just marvel on the
website as well DC Star Wars pop culture
in general The Last of Us stranger
things maybe even some music on there as
well but the main stuff that you guys
love Marvel DC some Star Wars stuff
that'll be constant updates every single
day on thecosmic wonder.com you have to
put the the cosmic wonder.com you can't
just put Cosmic Wonder that's different
site so thecosmicwonder.com and last but
certainly not least we have a Discord
server some of you may know this already
because I've promoted it a little bit in
the past but if you really want to be
involved with a cool Community with some
really great people check out our
Discord server I'll put that link Down
Below in the description and also with
the patreon the top tier is going to
give you access to a VIP server and from
there I'll be in that server I'll be
talking and you might have a chance to
be featured in a video we're going to
talk about theories and we're bringing
back a segment on the channel that I'm
super excited about we used to call it
Theory Thursday
that's not going to be the title now
we're gonna figure that out once we do
our first episode or we might do a poll
on Discord and patreon to figure out
what it's going to be called but
essentially I'll take the best theories
that are posted to the VIP Discord
server and we will go over them on the
channel so that'll be a segment that
hopefully we can do each week think of a
title right now put it down below if you
have an idea for the title so I'm really
excited for that so be sure to jump in
the Discord if you have Discord and you
want to chat with some really cool
like-minded people and look out for that
new segment on the channel again any and
all support is super appreciated even if
you just click on this channel every now
and then and you're not even subscribed
one subscribe please but if you aren't
and you just watch every now and then
that that even means so much to us like
thank you for even clicking on one video
of mine that that I've posted before I
super appreciate it any and all support
however big or small trust me it all
matters and I appreciate it so much and
I love you all so much and I've been
saying I love you three thousand but
since we've been in the Multiverse Saga
now I like to say I love you all in
every single universe so I hope to catch
you all on these other platforms hope to
communicate with you all through there
hope you enjoy the new content that is
coming as well hope you go to the
website and I'll catch you all in the
next video thanks so much for watching
wolf